let's take some questions from the
audience Neil wrote in saying hey David
what's the biggest lesson you've learned
from failure in life i have a very
specific story and I don't know if I've
told the story before on the show but
when I was a younger and work at circuit
city I lived at home you know I was in
high school then it was my first year at
college so I basically had no expenses
whatsoever so I was basically saving all
of my money I had a car so I paid for
you know insurance and gas and whatever
else and I would go out every once in a
while but it basically didn't spend any
money so I was saving all my money and
somehow i don't remember exactly how
through the internet do some kind of
like investor message board thing i got
in touch with someone who wanted to
raise some investment money for their
business and I don't even want to get
into the specifics of what kind of
business it was completely legal normal
business that involved the creation of
and sale of a product right a physical
product do you think it was one of those
spam messages there was no directly
reaching out to you someone and it
wasn't directly reaching out to me but
it was someone who was directly sort of
soliciting investors which by the way I
later found out general solicitations of
investors are not legal but I didn't
know that at the time I think I was like
19 years old or something like that and
I thought hey this isn't a I've heard
about in people investing in stuff I
should get in touch i I've saved some
money and I could invest this sounds
really good so I reached out to the
person was a real person I talked to the
person i traveled to where the person
was located and met with them and I said
you know what I'm going to invest in
this business at the time I knew nothing
about valuation of a business I was 19
year old kid I knew nothing about how to
calculate the potential return on an
investment and I got it in my head that
it was a good idea to invest what at the
time was a significant amount of money
for me for a four percent stake in the
business thinking wow this business
explodes imagine what it would be like
to own four percent of you know I was
imagining some really big business were
four percent it would be insane to own
four percent of such a big business and
of course the numbers didn't add up
write the numbers i was thinking of is
to how much this business was worth and
could be worth and
therefore what my four percent might be
worth none of it made sense because that
was a 19 year old who didn't know
anything right obviously I invested the
money I think it lasted for about 10 to
12 months during which the person in
charge of the business would tell me oh
oh we're doing this we're doing that and
we're going to do make these sales and
those sales and I was just too naive to
realize that none of it made sense even
if the things that I was being told
we're going to be done succeeded it
wasn't going to make my four percent
worth anything significant in terms of
you know in context with the amount that
I invested and I lost all the money and
I learned very quickly that that is not
the way to go about doing this type of
thing of course subsequently I got an
NBA I learned more formally how you
value businesses and went through the
investment process with the david pakman
show in terms of securing investment
money and i now realize more than ever
number one how naive and uninformed i
was at the time it was an expensive
lesson but a very important lesson that
i will never forget yeah i think another
one of those lessons there is if
something seems too good to be true it
often kind of is and it add hollywood
and you know do your preparation but you
know it's a better lesson to learn when
you're 19 and investing a relatively
small amount of money yes and now rise
if you know you're a little bit older
right it's an amount of money that Ben
was a lot but it didn't have the
repercussions that it would have if I
lost an equivalent amount of money now
when I actually have financial
responsibilities in life so it was much
better to learn the lesson then and I
still hear from people who are older and
they say i'm about to invest in this or
that and my alarms go off thinking back
to this and I try to tell them you know
you do what you want let me just tell
you this story because it sounds like
you're thinking about it in a similar
way and I don't want what happened to me
to happen to you you've got
responsibilities some of these people of
mortgages or kids or whatever and I
learned a lot any story that comes to
mind for you well seeing this wonderful
picture of someone falling off their
bicycle i remember in high school I
wanted to learn how to longboard with
some of my friends yeah and I would just
take on these hills that were just way
too challenging for me and I would be
going at a speed and maybe like 20
five miles per hour on the second day I
was learning to do it and I got to a
point where i was getting the wobbles
really bad going back and forth and you
know just kind of panicking my mind told
me to stand up as straight as I possibly
could which was a horrible thing because
I supposed to like lower your set of
gravity and bend your knees and you know
I fell quite horribly and you know
scraped up a bit so the lesson that I
took away for that in life is when
you're riding on a longboard you should
bend your knees yes a good lesson I had
a similar wobbly thing when I used to
have a motorcycle really and it started
to get a little bit wet outside and i
think it was about again interestingly
similar to the investment story 18 or 19
at the time and i hit a bump and when
you hit a bump i came down and my
handlebars were slightly turned yeah so
right when i hit they start sort of
doing a figure-eight motion which is
actually turning me in my chair as i say
this and it felt it was the most unsafe
feeling moment i had on the motorcycle
I'm very quickly i decided i think i'm
done i got rid of it and it's so fun to
ride a motorcycle but it just felt very
very dangerous at the time